Today we're learning English with one of the
most fascinating stories within the world of
Harry Potter, that of Severus Snape. So if you're
a Harry Potter fan this will surely bring some
nostalgia for you, and even if you're not, this
is going to be a great opportunity to learn tons
of vocabulary, expressions and more.
So let's apparate into the magical
world of Harry Potter.
This is indeed a pivotal
scene in the Harry Potter franchise, where you
learn a great deal more about Snape's backstory.
And by the way, if this is your first
time to Learn English TV Series,
I want to let you know that every single week
we make fun lessons with your favorite movies,
series and more, so that you can understand
fast speaking natives without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles.
Just like our fan Stéphane, who says that she
never gets bored with our lessons and is
making clear progress with her English.
And you will too, it's really simple: just hit
the Subscribe button and the Bell down below,
and you can join over 3 million learners
around the world, having fun learning English.
Hey, do you want to learn the
vocabulary that natives really use?
Well, with our Fluent with Friends Course
you can learn hundreds of the words and
expressions that you need to be able to
speak English fluently and confidently.
And it's so much fun it'll almost be like magic,
so you can try that absolutely FREE with our
3-Part Masterclass. Just click up here or down
description below to learn more and sign up!
Hey, are you a fan of Harry Potter? Well
we have plenty more lessons like this one!
You can find them in this playlist by clicking
up here or down the description below.